CATHY DAW: Datastax
delivers Apache Cassandra
to the enterprise.
Apache Cassandra is the
leading distributed database
that is built to be
agile, always on,
and predictably scalable.
We have around 30
software engineers
that are testing our product.
And they're testing
clusters of different sizes.
RUSSELL SPITZER: We call
up clusters and then run
a series of tests,
simulate these events,
and then we actually take
the entire clusters down.
CATHY DAW: When we started
looking at other Cloud
providers, one of the
challenges that we ran into
was that we would
always be asked,
well can you tell us exactly
what you're going to do
and when you're going to do it?
Google has a very
flexible cost model
that allowed us to not
have to think or plan.
RUSSELL SPITZER: One of my
favorite things about Google
Compute Engine is that
any calls that you
do in the UI can instantly be
translated into a REST call.
If we were launching a
particularly large set
of instances and
we know they're all
going to be configured
in a similar way,
the GC API makes
that really simple.
We have one set-up image
and then suddenly we'll
have 1,000 machines
that all look identical,
and it takes almost no time.
CATHY DAW: Google has been a
great company to work with.
We've gotten a lot of support
from our account executive who
took the time to understand
our multiple use cases.
RUSSELL SPITZER: It's
not a simple task
to set up a framework for
launching clusters and taking
them down and
installing products,
but Google was really
helpful and actually gave us
a lot of great ideas on how
to really efficiently launch
large numbers of machines
at the same time.
CATHY DAW: We didn't want
to constrain our engineers.
We wanted to enable
them to throw
what they can at the product,
to do the best that they could.